lille reçoit son panier de noël de la
banque alimentaire de son église et elle
est loin d'être la seule dès les débuts
de la pandémie on a triplé le nombre de
bénéficiaires habituels
des fruits des légumes elle ne croyait
jamais qu'un jour elle devrait demander
de l'aide pour se nourrir rappelant des
gros gros salaires puisqu'elle m'a donné
une séparation du temps de ce chômage
man notée monoparentales elle a épuisé
ses économies
la maladie il empêche de travailler elle
bénéficie depuis deux ans de l'aide de
dernier recours une réalité difficile à
accepter oh mon dieu
s'est fait un nom en auto puisse pleurer
je vous dise il raconte à café spawn et
basculer dans la pauvreté est une
réalité maintenant pour bien des
familles à faible revenu
l'accès au logement l'inflation la
pandémie c'est comment tu as fait que sa
page il y des gens qu'on pensait on dort
au canada c'est en saskatchewan et en
nouvelle écosse que les taux de pauvreté
sont les plus élevés sans compter les
territoires où la situation est critique
l'organisme canada wydad pauvreté craint
qu'avec au micro la situation se dégrade
votre guide 4 kg à sec c'est vous parce
qu'à l'épicerie le prix des denrées
augmente ce qui inquiète line on va
faire tout ce qu'on en parle le monde
s'en parle tout petit îlot abandonné
ce soit des gens capote avec ses petits
enfants qu'elle adore les notes
demeurent philosophe aujourd'hui je
mange aujourd'hui je peux partager
quelque chose demain stone journée mais
il ya manqueront pas ce qu'il y arrive
toujours selon nos besoins mais ils font
une croix ici marie josée paquet comme
radio canada montréal